This message comes from Greenlight. Ready to start talking to your kids about financial literacy? Meet Greenlight, the debit card and money app that teaches kids and teens how to earn, save, spend wisely, and invest with your guardrails in place. With Greenlight, you can send money to kids instantly, set up chores, automate allowance, and keep an eye on your kids' spending with real-time notifications. Join millions of parents and kids building healthy financial habits together on Greenlight.
Sign up for Greenlight today at Greenlight.com slash Odyssey. This episode is brought to you by Missouri. From November 25th to December 2nd, get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks, Missouri has something for everyone. Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials so you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them. Shop your wishlist 25% off at majori.com today. Welcome to Second Drink the Alliance. Jenna, I feel like we need a cat calendar
at front reception update. Well, they really made me wait for it this week. It's there, but you don't see it till 12 minutes and 50 seconds. 12 minutes? Cat calendar at reception. Yeah, yeah. Same calendar. Same cat, by the way.
The month has not changed. No flips. Nope. There is also next to the cat calendar a giant poster that says all hands meeting on Saturday from 9 a.m. to noon. It's been there for weeks. What are we meeting about? I don't know and are we meeting every Saturday? It doesn't specify. And spoiler alert, I checked ahead both the cat calendar and the all-hands meeting
are there through the end of season one. Noted. All right. Well, we'll have to see if they're in season two. You know I'll look for it. Well, I found a fun Michael Talkinghead that was in the table read draft for this episode. It reveals Michael's philosophy about sales and worker morale, how they're connected, and you know what? It sets up the whole birthday storyline,
and I wanted to read it to you. Oh, okay. Michael looks at camera and says, "'All salesmen are selling one thing, happiness, "'and ourselves.' "'Look at TV ads now. "'A guy in a tuxedo breakdancing in a park, "'and four hot girls jumping in a puddle.
And what are they selling? I don't know. Could be coffee, could be typewriters. It's a lifestyle. The happiness lifestyle. But here's the catch. You wanna sell happy? You gots to be happy.
The problem I'm facing is there's a lot of rumors going through the office about downsizing. Everyone is worried about losing their job. It's brought our happiness level to down to here. The bomb falling whistle was in the script. That's why I did it. Just looking at me like, what are you doing? It was said to do that.
It's brought it down to here. Not good. Time to call in a specialist. Professor me. And then the scene would have continued with Michael and Pam in his office, where he says that they need to boost morale by hosting a birthday party. Wow.
I love so much when he's like, what are they selling? I don't know. Could be coffee, could be typewriters. And there's one other thing. You know Jenna, in this breakdown of this episode you mentioned a deleted scene between Michael and Pam where he is coaching her on how to answer the phones. Oh yes, I remember shooting it even now. Well it's really funny and you describe it so well but we didn't play the clip and I think we should hear it. I agree. Dunder Mifflin this is Pam. Hold please.
Eww. Eww. Rady then. Well I see you're going for the whole bored supermodel thing. Dunder Mifflin this is Pam. May I help you? Smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke. I wasn't really going for anything. I get it, I get it. A child is born. Beautiful sunset. Now I'll catch the next one. Unicorn walks into the office. Do you have an appointment? Look, Pam, this is not meant as a criticism, but let me tell you what you're doing wrong.
You're the voice of this company, right? And when clients call and you're not smiling, they can hear that in your voice. It is a real turn-off. Are you being serious? Yes, I am, absolutely. So, the next call we get, I'd like you to smile. I'd like to see a big smile.
Okay. Okay. No one's calling. I know. Somebody will. And we'll wait. Sometimes there's a lot of time between the calls. I know. I know. We will wait.
Okay. We will wait for the calls. I knew, I knew, I knew. We will wait. Okay. We will wait for the call and you will smile. Let me try something just while we're waiting. Okay. Tell me if I'm smiling or not. Hi Pam, how are you? Was I smiling? Yes. Okay, let me try this one. Hi Pam, how are you? No. I mean you can tell. Yeah, I can tell. I was just smiling that time. And they can tell too. That was a good example.
Thank you. Alright, when we get a call I'll come back and you'll do the smile. Okay. It's shing time! It's shing time! Gunder Mifflin, this is Pam. One moment, I'll transfer you. Okay.
So, lady, so much of that was improvisation. And I can remember when he says, it's okay, we'll wait. We were supposed to just sit there and like stare at each other. And they just kept the camera rolling. And that's why I said, sometimes there's a long time between calls. Cause you're like, what are we doing? Yes, and then Steve improvised that whole thing
where he like puts his hands up in front of his face and he's like, am I smiling? Am I not smiling? And I was like, yes, no. And I'm like, that's a great example. You're so bored by him. We had so much fun. Well, you can actually watch that scene now
because it's included in the super fan episodes. Well, one of the things I love about this episode of our podcast is that we got to hear from Phil Shea in this episode. And it just, I love that we have his voice on the podcast forever. I know. Me too. All right. Well, here's our breakdown of the Alliance. And this Wednesday on Office Ladies 6.0, we have an all new episode.
We are kicking off the December holiday season with a request from our very own Cassie Jerkins. Yes, I can't believe I'm about to say this, but we are going to break down the Star Wars Christmas movie. Thank you, Cassie. Thank you. Now, Jenna, have you seen this? Nope. Not at the time we recorded this. It's really incredible. Like good? Incredible?
Yeah. Mm-hmm. Okay. I can't wait. That is on my docket between now and next Wednesday. Here is the Alliance. See you then. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hey, everyone.
It's Jenna Fisher. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey. We have a great episode. It's The Alliance. It's so Fisher. Hi, I'm Angela Kinsey. We have a great episode, it's The Alliance. It's so good. I was tickled. Can I tell you, I was tickled watching this. Same.
And I made my note cards, Jenna. I'm real excited about it. There are so many inside jokes from this episode for the office gang. We will get to that. Angela, I'm sorry, I think we have no time for chit chat this morning. What? We have no time, no, we have no time because this episode is too good.
There's too much to talk about. But Jenna, I love chit chat. I know. Well, you're going to have to save it. Well, I have really good day two hair for the ladies out there listening. I got a blow dry last night. This is what I said we don't have time for. This is literally what I just said.
I can't tell you how great my hair looks today and I didn't even brush it. I mean, the back of it's a hot mess. Let's, but you know, that's kind of my go-to. You are so proud of your hair that you had to get it in there even though I said we didn't have time. All right, Jenna, get to your dang fast facts. All right, The Alliance Season One, Episode Four.
I'm listening. This is written by Mike Schur and directed by Brian Gordon. Little bit of trivia, Mike Schur plays Moe's on our show. He does, he plays Moe's. Yeah, not yet, but. Not yet, and he's also just insanely talented. I mean, you know, look him up on IMDB.
He's like writing everywhere, he's everywhere. Yeah, he produces a million amazing television shows. If you're watching a television show and you love it, Mike Schur probably made it. Mike Schur's probably doing it. Yes. So I'm gonna start with a synopsis on this episode. I know we usually start with our fast facts.
Oh my god, what are you going, rogue? What's wrong with you? I know, I'm refusing to allow any chitchat. I'm starting with a synopsis. You're like in a black shirt with a black hoodie. You've got camel pants. What's happening? Are you taking a kickboxing class or something?
You know I took my kickboxing yesterday. I know, I know. So I'm feeling very tough. I know, you're my kickboxing yesterday. I know, I know. You're a badass. I know, you're very tough. All right, synopsis. So this episode has two basic storylines. One, in an attempt to raise morale, Michael insists on throwing a birthday party,
even though it's no one's birthday. It's no one's birthday. The closest birthday is Meredith, so it's next month, but he insists on throwing her birthday party. And then at the same time, Jim and Dwight form an alliance. Dwight is worried about the rumor downsizing, and so he goes to Jim and suggests they form an alliance. And this is like candy for Jim.
He's like, oh my God. Yes. Oh my God, this is such a great opportunity to mess with Dwight. Both of these themes are because people are afraid that the office is being downsized. This is a big theme of the first season of The Office. And so Michael thinks the answer is to throw a party and Dwight thinks the answer is to form an alliance and spy on his coworkers. Yes. You know, it's not Meredith's birthday, right? But we sort of forced this party, but it is Ryan the Tip's birthday.
Oh, yes. That's a little nugget at the end of the episode. It's such a great reveal at the end. Okay, I didn't mean to jump ahead. Okay. That's all right. Well, I'm going to give a little fast fact. So fast facts for anyone who's new to listening.
These are just a few fun facts about an episode that sort of are overreaching. They apply to the whole episode rather than just one scene. And for those of you just tuning in, Jenna came up with the idea of fast facts. That's right. And she really loves it. And I call her keeper of the notes. She is keeper of the notes, keeper of the records. She loves the list. Yes, Angela. She loves the list.
Anyone who has been listening regularly knows these two things. Oh, Jenna just cut some eyes at me. I'm telling you, the lady is sassy today. Well, and now we also know you have good hair today. OK, the first fast fact is that this episode was inspired by the television show, Survivor. Yes. Yes, the writing staff watched a bunch of episodes of Survivor,
and they did this so that they could properly satirize the way people talk about alliances and this idea of, you know, Ganging up against other people. And also though, you have to mention that our cameraman, Randall Einhorn and Matt Sohn, their background was Survivor. Yes, they were camera operators on Survivor, which for me, as a huge Survivor fan, You're a huge Survivor, which for me, as a huge Survivor fan. You're a huge Survivor fan. You guys, Jeff Probst officiated my wedding.
Now, this is something that, you know. This is true. Now, here's the thing. If you know Jenna, and she's like from St. Louis, she's a good Midwest gal. And I remember when you were planning your wedding, and you were like, Jeff Probst is going to officiate. And I was like, the guy from Survivor?
What is happening? So here's what happened. My now husband, Lee, and I, we were at an Emmys party. Now, I know out there people think that when you go to these parties, you become friends with people. But you really don't. You kind of hobnob.
You maybe take a picture, and then you never see them again. And you sort of stick with the people you already knew. Oh my gosh, I just would always sit like next to like Brian and Oscar and you and like I was terrified to like go meet people. You're better at it. I think you're better at it. Am I? Yes. Remember when you made me go up to Meryl Streep? That's a story for later. Yeah. And Amy Adams and And I said nothing. I look like such a dork. I just walked up and was like, buh. We had to meet Meryl Streep. I'm sorry, if you have a chance to meet Meryl Streep, you don't let that go.
Well, anyway, that's a great story, but we'll save it. OK, well, put a pin in that. So I ended up approaching Jeff Probst at this party. See? You would approach Jeff Probst. I would never go up to him. OK, go on. And I told him that I was a huge Survivor fan, and I was.
And we ended up really hitting it off, especially Jeff and my then-fiancee Lee really hit it off because they had tennis in common. They played tennis together. Oh, they were tennis pals. Yeah. So after this party, they ended up becoming tennis pals, and then we started going to dinners, couples dinners. Jeff's wife is so lovely.
Her name is Lisa. So we just ended up becoming great friends with them. And at one of our dinners, Jeff said that he was nervous because that upcoming weekend, he was going to be officiating a friend's wedding. And you were like, ding, ding, ding, ding. Jeff Probst is the type of guy where he is really caring and he's a, has a sort of just like a spiritual soul. I'll tell you one thing. Kind of like Rainn Wilson, right? Yes. I'll tell you one thing.
When you talk to someone like Jeff or Rainn, you feel like you're the only person in the room. Yes. And they're truly interested in you. They really want to know you. They care about what you care about. They're interested in you. And I thought, that's the kind of person
you want to officiate your wedding. You want that kind of soulful, caring person. But then also, he's a host. So he's comfortable commanding attention from a group of people. And it was awesome. You were there, Angela. It was awesome.
I was there. Here's my one story from your wedding. Jeff Probst, before your wedding, called me. He got my phone number from you and was like, can you tell me any stories about Jenna that you know from the years? And I was supposed to give a speech at your wedding, a toast. I was going to give a toast. You had asked me to give a toast. And I sort of told Jeff some of my stories about you that I was going to have in my toast. Oh no. And he stole them. He took some of my bits. And so then, like
when I got up to give my toast, I don't know if you remember, I'm like, I'm going to say a few things. I mean, Jeff Probst pretty much stole all my stuff, but whatever. And I like called him out for stealing my bits. So as you were watching the wedding, all you were thinking was like that he kept stealing your stuff. Yes. Dang it. Propsti. I told you and I called him Propsti. I made up a nickname for him. I'm sure he loved it. All right. Next fast fact. What? The original cut of this episode came in at 40 minutes, which is way too long because for a show to air on television on network TV, it can only be 20 minutes and 30 seconds.
Well, that's crazy. Because you need room for the commercials. Hey, network TV people, I just have a little tip for you. And I know you want me to weigh in on things. Change up your format. I know, because they had to cut out like half of what they wanted to cut. And Greg considered splitting this into two episodes. I wish they could take all the stuff they cut out
and re-release it all. Wouldn't that be so fun? I will tell you, on the Season 1 DVD, they have the deleted scenes from this episode, and they are delightful. I watched them, and most of what was cut out were really funny kind of general office life scenes.
So there was this great bit between Jim and Dwight where Dwight is changing his password, where he's going on and on about how his password on his computer is the best and Jim keeps guessing it. He's like, is it Frodo? And it is. And it is. And then there's another really great one of Dwight just cleaning out the fridge in the break room and he throws away Jim's tuna sandwich.
There was also a really great scene that when I was watching this deleted scene, I remembered shooting and it was so funny of Michael coaching Pam on how to answer the phone with a smile. Oh my Lord. He said that she sounded really gloomy. And he then stands by her desk and waits for the phone to ring. And there's just these long pauses. Awkward pauses. And then he does this funny thing where he puts his hands in front of his face and he
says, tell me if I'm smiling or not. Oh my Lord. He's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And she's like, yes, you're smiling. And then he's like, Dunder Mifflin, this is Michael. And I'm like, not smiling. And he's like, you hear the difference? And then I have this line where I'm like, that was a really great example. Thank you. But so there is a place if you're interested, the season one DVD has all of these deleted scenes on it. And you
know, by the way, the reason Greg couldn't split this up into two episodes, he thought of doing one episode that was just about throwing the birthday party and one episode that was just about the Alliance, the big prank. And then you could have filled it out with some of these general office life scenes. The problem was at the end of the episode, we all are have birthday hats. We all all are have birthday hats. We all have cake and birthday hats. And so the end of the Alliance part ends with birthday hats. And so he couldn't do it.
Jenna, I have some trivia on my note cards, but you need to tell me when you're done with your fast facts. So I have one more fast fact. I don't want to mess up your list. I see. I have. Don't look at my note cards. I can see one of my fast facts on your note cards.
Well, stop looking at my homework. Well, my goodness. Well, excuse me, Angela. Here's my last fast fact. Okay, do it. Near and dear to my heart and yours. This is the first time we meet the party planning committee. The PPC.
The PPC. Oh my gosh, just years of just lovely memories of us planning ridiculous parties. Oh my gosh. I remember that because I remember that there was just a tiny bit that was scripted. Yes. And then Greg told us, Greg Daniels said, guys,
just keep planning the party. Yeah, just, just. We're going to record you. Yes. And that's when Phyllis was naming colors, like what color streamers. And then we did this whole like we did a whole other tangent about do we say happy birthday or do we say surprise? Or do we say happy birthday surprise or surprise? Who would say that? You're right. We should start with surprise.
You say surprise first. And then Pam's just caught in the middle of you and Phyllis. And I love the dynamic of your subtle bullying of Phyllis. Yes. Your famous line, I think green is kind of horish, is in this episode. Yes. And Phyllis is of of course, wearing green. And then I throw her under the bus at the end.
I blame her for the lame streamers, the red streamers. I just love all of it. And there was so much that was there that got cut. And I know why. I mean, no one wants to watch like 20 minutes of us trying to plan a party. But it was so fun. I always felt like there could be a spinoff, like a web special called the Party Planning
Committee. The PPC. Oh my gosh. What if there was like this cool thing where they like uncovered all of the like unused footage of us planning parties. Oh my God. That's got to exist in a vault somewhere. Somewhere.
I would totally want to see it, but we did. We had so much fun. And we took such long pauses and it was so boring. It was so boring. And Pam was dying inside. My take on that scene was that I should speak very little. Like how I got roped into being on this committee, I feel like I was forced onto it by Michael. I don't think I volunteered.
And I just wanted the meeting to be over. And it didn't, you know, but you have that, have you been in those office? Oh my God, yes. I mean, come on, you and I both temped and we worked in offices. And I mean, yes, you've been in those meetings. It's that famous like line that people say like,
this whole meeting could have been one email. Yeah, that's that's what it is. You know, I have to point out my hairstyle in this party planning committee scene because that hairstyle was bonkers crazy. It was like, I don't know, we took two pieces and we twisted it back to the back of my head. And then we did a low ponytail that connected it. And I had so many rubber bands and pins holding it. And then I had one piece that kept flopping out and it drove me crazy. And by the end of the episode, I was like, I don't ever want this.
I can't do this again. I can't have this hairstyle again. You can do whatever you want, but this weird multiple rubber band, I can't do it again. Angela, I feel like we've come full circle here. We started by speaking about your hair and now we're speaking about your hair again. It's almost like, it's almost perfect. This must make you so happy, Jenna.
It does. And I take it back. I think that you were right to have that banter. I will take that, Jenna Fisher. Let's take a break and then we'll come back and we'll start to really dive into this episode scene by scene. Okay. Oh, let's do it. This episode is brought to you by Missouri.
From November 25 to December 2, get 25% off everything on orders over $150 in Missouri's biggest sale ever. From bold hoops to minimalist stacks, Missouri has something for everyone. Missouri makes handcrafted fine jewelry for every day made with responsibly sourced materials. So you can look and feel good about gifting and wearing them. Shop your wishlist 25% off at majorey.com today.
Light up Black Friday with Freedom Mobile and get 50 gigs to use in Canada, the U.S. and Mexico for just $35 a month for 18 months. Plus, get a one-time gift of 5 gigs of Rome Beyond Data. Conditions apply. Details at FreedomMobile.ca. your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. Well, welcome back. Welcome back. We are talking about the Alliance. Let's get into it, Jenna.
All right. The very first scene in this episode is Dwight waiting outside of the bathroom to confront Michael about the downsizing rumors. And I just have to say, we do this a lot to Michael and it always makes me laugh. First of all, how much time does he spend in the bathroom? And whenever people want to talk to them, they, because this already happened, Oscar waits outside the bathroom to confront him. Yes. We're always bombarding him outside of the restroom.
Well, I think it's because Michael is always avoiding us. He's like, he always is avoiding work, right? Yes, unless he has a joke to tell or unless he has good news. Yes, otherwise he hides. And so people wait for him outside of the bathroom and he's always startled. I have a lot of empathy for him because as a mother, I feel like every time I go to the bathroom, someone is literally waiting outside the door for me.
Always. Always. I don't understand it. What is that? Why can't mothers go to the bathroom without someone outside the door? I don't know. You know, I have such like empathy for my parents now in a different way. I remember my dad going to the bathroom one time and I was outside the door like, and I think I was like messing with the door. I was like doing like click, click, click, click on the door, click, click. And my my dad was like I'm just trying to go to the bathroom and I was like hey dad he's like he just needed five minutes just five minutes five minutes my kids slide things under the door always slide things under the door like that drawing couldn't wait no or they just
open the door or they just come on in I know I. I know. Okay, sorry. Okay, anyway, poor Michael is accosted as he comes out of the bathroom once again. I have like a fun little Dwight thing that I noticed in rewatching this. What? So it is such a joy for me to go back and rewatch these episodes. I know you're having a lot of fun with it too, but I always thought the first bobblehead that Dwight ever had was the one that my character gave him for Valentines. Really? Of himself.
I knew that wasn't true. What? Yes, the reason your character made him a bobblehead of himself was because of his love of bobbleheads. It's just maybe something you want to look into for your character, Anne. What? Really? Yes. That's...
Was it a known thing that Dwight loved bobbleheads? Yes, he has them on his desk. Oh my God. Wow. How did I miss that? Shinnit is now looking at me like I might need to take medication for something. Oh my God. That just occurred to you now in the rewatch?
That just occurred to me. I thought he was so excited because I gave him a bobblehead. Oh my god. Oh my lord. I am a dingbat. Okay. I wrote on my note card. You have to hear what I wrote. I'm such an idiot. Dwight has a bunch of bobbleheads! Exclamation point!
Baseball team! I counted six bobbleheads! Are they from the Phillies? Oh my God. How many times did I walk past his desk and I didn't notice that. Because he collected bobbleheads, your character makes him a bobblehead of himself. That's where your character got the idea. It's a good thing you don character got the idea. I hit my head. It's a good thing you don't write the show.
I hit my head on the microphone. Oh my God. How did I miss that? So this I think is an example of how fans of the show might know it better than some of the people on it. Oh my God. As Angela is pointing out a fact of the show that landed on everyone else but her. I was so excited. Look at my note cards.
So many exclamation points, guys. I put so many, six bobbleheads. They're all baseball players. I do have some other good note cards coming up. Let's see another note card. We'll decide. Okay. All right, sassy pants.
I put an asterisk by this one because I thought it was so good. Do you know that there is a continuity error? Aha! Oh, look at your face now, Jenna Fisher. Alright, I don't have this in my note. Oh, I know. There's a continuity error. What is it? And it's in accounting at seven minutes. At seven minutes, Michael is talking about what he's going to write on the birthday birthday card. And he says, and you know what guys, I have set the bar really high. Oh, Sam, pull it up, pull it up on the screen.
Sam is here in the booth, he's gonna show Jenna. I'm at the copier at the beginning of this talking head behind Michael. I'm in my beige sweater that I wear through the whole episode with my crazy ponytail. All right. And then it cuts to me at my desk during his talking head and I'm in a white t-shirt, a white button down with a black sweater vest and a different hairstyle.
They edited in a different piece of footage to cut to and I'm completely- You're in a different outfit. Completely from a different episode. I'm in a white button down and a black sweater I'm looking at it now. I see it beige sweater. Okay over Michael's shoulder through the window at the copier Jim wrote Meredith I heard you're turning 46, but come on. You're an accountant. Just fudge the numbers Not bad pretty funny see me at the copier. I don't appreciate condoning corporate fraud though. Now. I leave the copier I go to my desk.
Go to your desk. This is apparently when you're changing clothes. Yes. So what are you doing back there? You're putting on a... People out there are expecting. I've already set the bar really high. Oh, look at that!
Look at that, I'm in a completely different outfit. Ha ha. Whoa, I have something else to talk about in this scene. But okay, can you just say though, okay, maybe I fumbled the bobblehead moment, but I did catch a continuity error. Okay, I will not. Suck it, suck it. Okay, I'm giving that to you.
I didn't see it. I didn't see it. Thank you. You saw it. I saw something. I did it. So you saw something too. What did you see?
Well, I'm not going to take credit for this. This was from isrosis on Twitter. IZrosis, capital IZrosis on Twitter mentions that in this moment when Michael's reading Jim's comment, Jim references that Meredith is an accountant. Yeah. Wait, we just watched the scene and you didn't catch that. Because I was looking at my outfit. You were looking at your outfit.
I was listening to the words and I heard it too. That's just a dig. I heard it as well. So you know, her question was, what's up with that? I thought there were three accountants. Why does he say you're an accountant? Just fudge the numbers. This is another continuity error.
Another. So here's something that I have at home. Okay. That is an amazing thing. It's called the show Bible. Okay. Do you know what a show Bible is for a TV show? I do. Okay, you know, let's explain it to people. A show Bible is a giant document. I mean, like thousands of pages. It looks like a phone book. It looks like a phone book. And in it, it lists every character and every fact about them. And every episode, if we learn something new about them, it gets put in the Bible. Yes. So it says our job, it says our relationships to people. I have a copy of the show Bible for the office.
Wow. How I got this, I don't know. I mean, there's probably only like two or three of them. Yes, I know. And I think I borrowed it. Jenna. Because I, over the summer. And you didn't give it back?
Yes, I think this is true. Over the summer from season eight to season nine, Greg Daniels came to John and I and asked us if we had any ideas for our final character arc in season nine. And he said, if it helps you, you can borrow the show Bible. So wait, Greg, I think Jenna has your show. I've got if you've been looking for it.
Maybe I shouldn't be saying this out loud because I really love my show Bible. I could probably make a copy before I return it. I think you should make a copy. According to the show Bible, Meredith's job is customer service rep slash supplier relations. She is not an accountant. No, she's not an accountant. No, and Isrosis said, what is her job? Because I know she's not an accountant.
So that's your answer. Also, Kelly is a customer service rep. And I remember there was a bit of a story where we put her back in that other room in the annex back by Toby because she talked too much. She was too chatty, and she was bothering Meredith. So they moved her back there. But really, the reason she sat back there
was because she was a writer, and they didn't want her to waste her writing time doing background work. Yeah, so she had to be separated so she could get out to write. But they made it a story point. You know what Greg said one time, we had a new writer one season and he was talking to me, they were gonna be giving like food in the episode
and they handed me like this steak or whatever and I was like, well, my character's a vegetarian. And he was like, oh, I didn't realize that. And I was like, yeah, my character is a vegetarian. And then Greg was like standing next to me and he was like, oh, I didn't realize that. And I was like, yeah, my character is a vegetarian. And then Greg was standing next to me, and he was like, you know what? Anything you want to know about each of their characters, just go talk to them. They know their character. They know sort of like the canon of all.
They've lived every episode, and they know their individual character story so well. I didn't know your character was a vegetarian. When do we establish that? It's established early on. And then it's throughout all the years. Like at Diwali, I was like, I guess I'll just eat naan. Whatever. Naan? Like there's like a whole thing.
Oh, I'm going to look it up in the show Bible. Okay, look it up in the show Bible. Maybe we should, well, let's get back to this episode a little bit. We got on a tangent. Oh, me and you on a tangent? Get out of town. Hard to believe. What are you even talking about? All right, so there's this scene early on where Pam and Michael are stuck in the office together. And I remember I could not get through this scene. There's this never-ending drum roll where Michael wants me to announce who has a birthday coming up. And he also calls you his assistant in this, which I think is hilarious. He has such a grandiose view of his job and who he is.
You are his assistant. You're not front reception for the whole company. You're Michael's assistant. Right. His personal assistant. You're his personal assistant. Which is not true. And he does this never-ending drum roll on the desk that was making me laugh.
And he wants me to announce whose birthday is coming up. And I say, there's no birthdays. And he's like, well, next one, next, just who is it? So then I say, well, Meredith's birthday is next month. And then I'm just, I am just giving him nothing in the scene and he starts swooping his phone across my face to see if he can find signs of life. Yes.
I cracked up. Oh my gosh. He was so funny when he was doing that. I just remember when I was rewatching this, I just remember losing it. But that's sort of where we set up that storyline, is that we now have to throw a party for Meredith, whose birthday is next month.
This is like a real dork thing. But when I watch these early scenes of Michael's office, it looks so different over the years. There's that shelf in the corner. He doesn't have the tall standing shelf with two doors. It's a different lower shelf. I don't know if you like look at all that. And I'm like, oh, his office,
like the furniture in his office keeps changing. This is a super nerdy thing for me to notice, but I mean, I don't notice bobble heads, but if you're gonna- You're gonna notice a major story point. If you're gonna move a cabinet, I'm gonna notice. So the next big sort of plot point scene is Rain asking Jim if he wants to form an alliance.
And this produced one of our inside joke lines. He asks him if he wants to form an alliance and Jim pauses and then he says, absolutely I do. And we used to say that to each other on the set. That used to be a thing, absolutely I do. I we used to say that to each other on the set. That used to be a thing. Absolutely. I do. I love this so much because it's just like Jim finally gets to have fun at work. This is like one of his favorite days you would think, right? Because otherwise it's just the monotony of it all. And Dwight does drive him crazy. And he talks about how crazy that Dwight makes him and he
finally gets to like really mess with him at Dwight's invitation. That is the best. He has that talking head where he says, sometimes it's just handed to you. I mean, you're thinking, how can I mess with this guy? And then here this wonderful gift comes. So after they decide to form the alliance, he says, don't tell anyone, you can't tell anyone. Right. Jim's like, of course not. And then Jim immediately comes up to the reception desk and tells me that he's formed an alliance with Dwight. And you see Dwight hovering in the background, listening in, and he wants to get Jim away from me.
So he has this line where he's like, Jim, can I talk to you about the paper products? So I listen to the DVD commentary of this. And I guess in that scene, they have a bunch of takes where Rain, every time he would change the end of the line. And I think it was Mike Schur said his favorite alt of that was, Hey, Jim, can I talk to you about the da ba da ba? He just like mumbles something that you couldn't even hear. I love that. I also loved like John Krasinski as Jim. You could just see John, I think because we
know him, having so much fun. When they go into the kitchen and Dwight's like, what are you doing? He's like, I'm working her. He's like, I'm working her. You know, like he's like, I'm on this, okay? Like I just saw John, like our friend John having so much fun in that moment. And it just made me smile. It's so cute the whole way that he is winding Dwight up in this episode. It happens again where he goes into the kitchen
where he's supposed to be spying on Toby and Kevin who are having lunch. Oh my god, that conversation is the most ridiculous, like amazing, boring conversation. Yes, and that produced another most frequently quoted inside joke line on The Office, which is when they're talking about the bread, and then John's take on that line, he says, their bread is very good, very good. We would do that all the time. And then here you are, the bread maker. Oh my gosh, pull circle life moment. Guys, my bread is very good.
Thank you. Also, we cannot not talk about the fact of how eagerly Pam is to join in Jim's prank and becomes a huge participant like in pulling this prank on Dwight. Oh yes, yes. Well this is their opportunity to spend time together. Any opportunity to team up with Jim. I mean, in the deleted scene we established that the phone rings very infrequently. Which we could probably have guessed anyway. This is so much fun for her.
She's having so much fun and Jim is just loving it. And his talking head about like how brilliant you were that you just came up, Pam came up with that all on her own. Yeah, when I come up to his desk and I'm like all fraught with it. Oh, I just don't know. Michael's told me so many things and I want to unload all these secrets, but he told me not to. And I'm doing that all so that Dwight can overhear it. Dwight's like jackpot.
But Jim is just so enamored with Pam and the scene. And you know what? I'm a jam fan, you guys. I am. And I love their storyline. I was just like a total fan of them. And I remember like every little nugget they had together. I was like, oh my god. And this is definitely one of those episodes. Should we take a break? I don't know. Do you
want to take a break? Please take us to a break. Oh my god. Miami Metro catches killers and they say it takes a village to race one. Anyone knows how powerful urges can be? It's me. Catch Dexter Morgan in a new serial killer origin story. Hunger inside of you. It needs a master. Featuring Patrick Gibson, Christian Slater, special guest star Sarah Michelle Geller with Patrick Dempsey and Michael C. Hall as Dexter's inner voice. I wasn't born a killer. I was made.
Dexter Original Sin, new series streaming December 13th. We're back. All right. All right. So another big part of this episode is Oscar baiting Michael into donating to his nephew's walkathon charity. But Michael sort of not getting nephew's walk-a-thon charity, but Michael sort of not getting what a walk-a-thon is, and so he puts in this big bid. And this is an example also of the benefit of the documentary crew element
of the show, because you can tell at first when Oscar walks into his office and asks him if he'll donate to his nephew's charity He doesn't want to he would if the cameras weren't there. He would probably say no, right, right But he can't say no look like a good guy He wants to look like a good guy. And so then he goes over the top and he donates $25 and only later is it brought to his attention that it's $25 per mile. Yes, exactly. And that realization happens in a great scene with Jim at the birthday party. And there
is just this long pause. I'll tell you what, Steve Carell is better than anyone at letting an emotion wash across his face. And you watch that emotion of like, oh crap, like just like, oh, what'd I do? Like go across his face. And I feel like we see this again in Fun Run, right? Because he like signs up to do like so many miles and he doesn't realize. Something about Michael does not understand the concept of a walkathon. A walkathon or anything like that. But no, that is so good. What like something about Michael does not understand the concept of a walk-a-thon or
anything like that. But no, that is so good. Well, I did. I added it up because in the in the episode, Michael, once he realizes it's per mile, he asks Oscar like, Hey, how strong is your nephew? Like, is he in good shape? Does he fit? So Michael has pledged $450. I did the math. He thinks he's pledged 25, but instead he pledged $450. I also need to go back. I skipped something that I think is really a fun thing. In the parking lot, there's a scene where Jim and Dwight, what am I going to say? It was Phyllis's car. It was Phyllis's car. Jim and Dwight are standing next to a car and they are comparing notes about everybody
in the office and what they've learned. And they're standing next to a car and it's Phyllis's car. Yes. And Rain, as Dwight, keeps kicking the car. Yeah. And Phyllis. She didn't care for it. She was very nervous about it.
And I guess at some point she went up to Rain and said, listen, it's totally fine if you kick my car, but don't kick the car or the hubcap, just the tire. Just the tire. We used to park our cars in that little parking lot. Yeah. A lot of our real cars have appeared as cars in the show. And then they, in seasons later, they had us move our cars. I think maybe they realized there's like liability
or something. I mean, so, but in those early they had us move our cars. I think maybe they realized there's like liability or something. I mean, so, but in those early days, those were our cars. A very, very big element of this episode is the point where Dwight ends up in a box in the warehouse to spy. And more than any other question, when I put this out to fans for questions, the most questions that we got, the most frequently asked questions were about this box.
How long was rain in the box? How many takes did we do? How many boxes did we use? One of the questions was, there's a scene where Pam is on the phone doing a fake phone call and the box kind of tips over. And I laugh and run off. Wait, I have a note card about this.
What is it? Okay, I know you put it out to Twitter, but this is your BFF. So I get to, can I ask you first? You get the first question. Jenna question, semi-pollin. Did you really break and laugh by the box? I think you did because I know what happens
to your shoulders when you really laugh. This was the question. Ah! This is the question that people wanna know. I think I faked it. What? Yeah, I don't think I really broke. I don't wanna believe that. I know, I think, because I remember shooting that scene
and I remember it was very technical. Okay. So it was, it was happening over. Okay. So it was, it was happening over my shoulder. Stuff was happening on my shoulder, but there was a way where they wanted me to break at a certain moment. So it was kind of technical. So you had to sort of get out of the way
and the box was tipping. Yes, exactly. So I remember shooting it a number of times and I remember thinking to myself, gosh, does this even look real? Like do I, it's a really, there are two things that I think are really hard to do when you're acting. One of them is cry, but I think people would expect that.
But the other is to laugh convincingly. Yes, you know who has the best fake laugh is Steve Carell. Steve Carell can do this fake laugh that is the most honest, genuine laugh. And every time he would do it, I would start to laugh. Even though I knew it was a fake laugh that is the most honest, genuine laugh. And every time he would do it, I would start to laugh, even though I knew it was a fake laugh. It was so contagious. He is the best at it. I find it's easier to cry than to fake laugh myself. Fake laughing is very difficult. It is. The reason I think that I didn't really break
is because I remember having anxiety over whether or not anyone was gonna buy it. Jenna I have a little something on my note card here. What is it? I have another note card I wrote this is the first time we see Darryl. Yes, yes when rain pops out of the box at the end Darryl is down there. Now he is not gonna have a big scene we're not to hear him speak until the next episode, which is basketball. Yes. But that is the first time we see Daryl. So I was very excited. I know. And look, my note card came in handy.
I love that about her. I love how we plant seeds that grow later. Right. We don't, that is a person who is going to be a major character on the show, but we introduce him just as a guy seeing rain come out of the box. Yeah, that is one of the things, and I know we say it over and over, and we will for the life of this podcast,
but one of the things I love about what Greg Daniels did is he starts in the middle. He doesn't like spoon feed you information, just the way they designed the show, you play catch up as an audience member. You're just like a day in the life and you're right in the middle. And I love that.
Yes, I love that too. Okay. Here's a big confession about the box. This is gonna blow your mind. What? Rain wasn't in the box most of the time. Who was in the box? Who's in the box?
Who was in the box? Phil Shea, our prop. Prop guy. Yeah. Phil Shea. Phil Shea is a very tall person. Yeah, well, so is Rain. And he was in that box all the time.
So most of the box acting was done by Phil Shea, of course, except for the end where Rain busts out. And comes back. So in that scene where I'm cracking up, Phil Shea was in the box. Oh my gosh. You know what I think we should do, Angela? Tell me, Jenna. I think we Yes. Phil Shea was in the box. Oh my gosh. You know what I think we should do, Angela? Tell me, Jenna.
I think we should call Phil Shea and get him to answer all of our questions about the box. Let's do it. What was it like in the box? Phil Shea, we are about to blow up your phone. Hello? Phil? Yes.
Phil Shea, it's Jenna and Angela. Hi, Phil. Oh, hey guys, how are you? Good, how are you? Thank you so much for letting us call and bug you. It's always a pleasure to help out Pam and Angela. Oh my gosh. Phil, thank you so much.
It's just so nice to hear your voice, I have to say. That's what I was thinking. I was like, gosh, it's so nice to hear your voice. Hey, what an experience we had for nine years, right? Yes, we were the luckiest. We were the luckiest. Well, if you have a second, Phil, can we ask you some questions from the Alliance episode? Absolutely.
So, we opened up questions to the fans and overwhelmingly the thing people wanted to know about was the box that Rain gets into in the warehouse. Oh my gosh. They wanted to know how long he was in the box, everything about the box, but Phil, I know you were in the box. Rain only got in after all the shooing and the scooching and the plodding and then the tumbling was done. Yeah.
Phil, you did all of that in the box. You were the scoocher and the tumbler and all that. I was. Apparently Mr. Zbornak, our line producer, didn't think we had enough money to hire a stunt guy. So he assigned me to be in the box. And I remember I had to go out and buy my own elbow pads and knee pads. And then I had a loose walkie talkie in there with me with Liz Ryan, who was the first AP,
shouting out all of Brian Gordon, who was our director for that episode's command. I remember like it was yesterday. So Phil, can you take me through it from the beginning? You get a script and it says, this character has to be in a box. So what do you do? Cause you're in charge of getting the box
as the prop master. So where do you start? On that particular prop, I just, I saw out Greg Daniels and I said, do you see Rain sitting down squatting in the box or does he kneeling down on his hands and knees and he said kneeling on his hands. And Rain is tall, Rain is tall, right?
And so are you Phil, you're very tall. Yeah, Rain is I think 6'1 or 6'2, I'm 6'1 if I blow dry my hair. You do have great hair. Like you guys should know, Phil has an amazing head of hair. He really does. This is true. I least it.
I least it. It's a Hollywood fake hairdo. But I tracked Rain down, and I asked him to get on his hands and knees, and I was a designer for this box. Wait, you made Rain get on his hands and knees, and then you measured him? And you measured him to know how big a. That was season one, Rain was willing to do anything.
Then I went to a couple box cities around Southern California, no one had a box close to that. So then I went onto the internet and I looked at box manufacturers in Southern California. I found a company in San Diego named Kent Landsberg and you have to understand as prop people we have a very short production time and lead time to get all these props so I called this Kent Landsberg paper
company and asked to speak to the manager and in a much more frenetic and hyper voice I said look you got to help me out I have to have a custom box made I probably need about a hundred of, and they need to be the dimension. And San Diego's like three hours away, too. Well, and also, that's such a good point. You didn't need one box. You needed 100 boxes, because you didn't know how many takes we were going to do.
And Brian Gordon, the director of this episode, ended up being notorious for doing tons of takes. So you were right to cover your bases and get a hundred. Yes. Right. And we shot that scene in the Dunder Mifflin warehouse. We wanted to have some boxes on the shelves and that was it. Oh, right.
Just ones that he didn't bust out of. Yeah, of course. Right. It wasn't a prop box. It just appeared out of nowhere. So we had to give some legitimacy to where it originated from. Look at all the detail. Look at all the details. So how did you do it? This guy said he would do it no problem and then how'd you get them? Well I talked to him he said the lead time is usually
a month and a half. I said we have four days. I said I need the boxes in four days and I said it was for a tv show. He said it's for the office which is a remake of the British version. And he probably said I'm sorry I'm a huge fan of the British version and I'm not was for a TV show. He said it's for The Office, which is a remake of the British version. And he probably said, I'm sorry, I'm a huge fan of the British version and I'm not interested in helping you. I had never heard of your show. It's like you guys were listening into the phone call, that's exactly what he said.
No, he said he would be glad to make an exception for a TV show. So he made it happen. We got the boxes delivered to Culver City, which is where we shot that episode in our first season. And then they put the graphics on the box and we had them back two days before we were filming. So we had it all done and rain fit in the box fine.
And then it was just about coordinating where the holes would be inserted by me when I'm inside the box with Dwight's Swiss Army knife. And it was a great scene. I mean, I remember we shot that down. I think it was a Friday night we shot that scene, but it was fun. Everybody was laughing. The crew was always we shot that down. I think it was a Friday night we shot that scene, but it was, it was fun. Everybody was laughing.
The crew was always laughing on that show and, uh, it was a great standing goal and fans love it so much. Oh, Phil, thank you so much. I have, I'm looking at a picture that I can email you that Michael Gallenberg gave me. I'm going to send you a picture as soon as we hang up of me getting ready to tape up a fist box. And I don't know if you have the Oh my gosh. the picture on the podcast but I'm gonna take a picture. We can put it on our website maybe. Yeah. Yeah. Okay I'll take a picture and you can see by the expression on my face after
about take 50. You were like in a sweat lodge. Oh Phil, thank you. But Jenna, you were there, and you remember the last take when Brian Gordon said one more, I hope you remember this, where he had me do all this stuff, and then when I cut myself out of the box, everybody had went and hit. Oh, and that's right. I came out into the warehouse, so he at least played a practical joke on me at the end to make me laugh, so that was pretty funny. We did. We left you in the box, and we pretended like we were were still filming and then you just were there for so long. That is horrible.
Why were we so mean? Phil, I would have if I was there Phil, I would have come up and said, Phil get out. They left. It was so funny. No, it was very funny. It was a great scene. Phil, I do. Can I throw two questions at you really quickly before we let you go? Two more? Oh, okay. Okay, so after getting this box, sounds like it was a massive undertaking. Phil, your job is sounding really fun.
Like you read an episode and then you have to come up with all these weird objects and gags. It sounds fun and stressful, Phil. Like how do you get 100 boxes in four days? It's always fun. It's always stressful. And it's great to be, like I said, a small part of a production that resonates with viewers
and fans across generations as The Office did. So it is fun. It is stressful. But it's a real joy to do it. When everybody laughs and everybody enjoys the prop and it adds a little value to the scripted scene and then we all go home and laugh and have a good day. So yeah, we love it.
Well, we sure appreciate you and we are gonna be calling you a lot, the office ladies. So thank you. Thanks for taking the time, Phil. I have vivid memories of all the props we made for the office, so anytime you guys wanna call me, get behind the scenes. Can we? Okay, because as you were talking,
I had like eight questions about different episodes down the road. So, I did too. We will definitely be calling you back, Phil. Thank you so much. We miss you. Yeah, let's keep Dunder Mifflin going. I miss you as well. Let's keep Dunder Mifflin relevant for the next 30 years.
I love it. Yay! All right, Phil. Well, have a good day. Yeah, tell everyone we say hi over there. Okay. I will. Thanks, Angela. Bye.
Bye. Thank you, bye. What's next, Jenna? I have three note cards left. Well, now we need to talk about the cake. Oh, yes. The ice cream, the mint chocolate chip ice cream cake. Yes. I got so sick. We chocolate chip ice cream cake. Yes.
I got so sick. We ate that cake. This is the second most frequently asked question was about the cake and what the cake was like and did we really eat the cake? Oh, we ate that cake, you guys. And guess what? You start filming, we would start filming at 7.30 AM.
So at 7.30 AM, you're gonna eat ice cream cake? Someone had you a plate of ice cream cake at 7.30 AM. And you're gonna eat ice cream cake? Someone hands you a plate of ice cream cake at 730 a.m. And you're gonna eat it for five hours? All day. All day. And then they're like, let's break for lunch. And you're like, I wanna puke. Yeah. Let me say something about prop food.
Oh, do it. BJ Novak loves prop food. Mindy Kaling loves prop food. I also kinda like it. I get real excited when I have to snack in a scene. I do not because I know it's gonna turn on me. I know and it turns on me every time and I still make the same mistakes. Every time. I would see Ed Helms, Minnie Kaling, you, BJ be like,
ooh, brought food and get so excited and be like, guys, pace yourself. It's gonna get gross. We'd have a party in the conference room and they'd have like pigs in a blanket and you just, me and BJ would be over there. I'd be like guys slow down. I know. You're gonna have to eat that for four hours. I know. Well this was the first time that I made the mistake and I started wolfing down ice cream cake early. And then you have to match that in every shot. So whatever you do in that first shot you then have to match it. So continuity wise, it all makes sense.
And here's the thing, I'm in the background of most of the ice cream eating scenes. What are you thinking? So I was wolfing it down in the background. She didn't have to, she was in the background. I was in the background. And then by the time it was time for my closeup, I was so sick.
I didn't wanna eat the ice cream cake, but then I had to. I'll tell you this, I was so sick. I didn't want to eat the ice cream cake, but then I had to. Nicole Soule-I'll tell you this. I had a slice and Michael walks up to Phyllis and I, and when he walks up, poor Steve is like wolfing the cake down as he's talking. Nicole Soule-He would eat a full piece every take. Nicole Soule-Oh man, they eventually got a bucket though that he could spit. Nicole Soule-Which is also disgusting. Nicole Soule-It's called a spit bucket.
Nicole Soule-It's called a spit bucket. It's called a spit bucket. But he would walk up eating the cake and he was talking to Phyllis and Meredith and my character and I was just going to take one bite as he walked up. And by the end of the five hours of doing the scene, when I would scoop up that one bite my hand would start to shake because I was anticipating it. So I was like, oh, yes, your body was rejecting. My body was rejecting it. It was like, please don't put that mint chocolate
chip ice cream in your mouth one more time ever again for the rest of your life. I can't eat it. I can't eat it. I can't eat it now. My daughter loves mint chocolate chip. I don't want it near me. I loved ice cream cake in general.
No. And only it was last year for my son's seventh birthday, I finally ate a piece of ice cream cake again. But that's, it had been like, I'd gone on like a 15 year moratorium. So the final thing I think we should talk about with this episode. Oh yeah, let's go on that note. Is the scene with Roy coming into the office
and confronting Jim. You guys are so busted. I remember like being over in accounting being like, oh, and also David Denman can be scary when he wants to be. He can be intimidating. He's such a teddy bear in real life. I know, but when he came in like that, I was like, he's a big guy. And I think he turns my character on because he's such a man. Like, you see that play out later where I'm like, I'm clearly, like, enamored with Roy. But in that moment, I was like, oh my god, Roy is going to kick Jim's ass.
Yeah, your character Angela likes a beefy alpha male, for sure. She just does. That's true. So I remember this scene. I remember breaking it down. We shot a ton of versions of this scene because we really didn't know how big of a reaction
Roy should have. So the first thing I remember was that somehow in the scene, when Jim and I are giggling about our accomplishment, we had to find a way to hold hands. That there had to be like- An organic way. An organic way where his arm is around me. There had to be something,
because Roy has walked in the door before and seen Jim standing at reception talking to me. So we had to come up with this reason that John would come around the front of the desk. He's so excited. Yeah, he's so excited that he jogs around. So instead of coming up to me with the desk between us, which is what you've seen in the past, this was a big moment. He breaks that barrier.
He comes around the desk. He puts his arm on me. We end up kind of holding hands and giggling. And I remember us really struggling to make sure that it looked real and organic and not staged. We didn't want to do something so out of the ordinary that you would be expecting something to happen. Right.
And I think we accomplished it. And then when he burst in the door, there were a couple of takes where he pushed Jim up against a wall, where he got really more physical with Jim. And so we shot all these different versions so that we could get it just right. Right. And the version they went with is the best. I think if Roy had gotten too physical there, it just would have taken us all out of it. Cause we'd be like, whoa. But I think just how ticked off he was. And then I thought John was brilliant in that moment.
He was so believable when he was like, I don't even know how to explain this. Cause he realizes how ridiculous their whole day has been. And how do you explain what they've been doing? Yeah. And they're so busted though. I know. It is a moment that made me totally cringe.
Yeah, and you know that Pam and Roy had words about that. Oh, the car ride home. The car. Yes, yes, car ride home. That was a tough one. My husband and I always talk about that. It will be at a dinner party or something, and you see a couple have like an awkward exchange, I'll like lean over to my husband and be like, oh, car ride home, car ride homes. That's kind of be a rough one.
So that's it. That's the Alliance. Can I say one more thing? I want to say one more thing. This episode has a special place in my family's life. Why? Because while we were shooting this episode, they got me out early so that I could go home for my sister's wedding. My real sister's wedding, I had to travel. So she got married while we were shooting this episode and this year she celebrated her 15th wedding anniversary. Aww.
Isn't that sweet? So when I was watching this, I remembered that. That's like a fun full circle life moment too. I know. Well, this is the thing you guys are going to hear a lot as we do this podcast is, you know, this show spanned 10 years of our lives and so much life happens in those 10 years. And we really do have all these special memories of our own lives mixed in with what was happening on The Office. And I feel like it shows because we all became
so invested in each other's lives. We are our own misfit family. Like the cast of The Office, the people that played the characters on The Office in real life have a lot of shared life moments and memories. And I think it just makes the show special to me. So when I watch it, I remember things too. Yeah.
And it's just so, I love that you shared that. Yay. OK, that was the alliance, everyone. That's right. Don't judge me for the bobblehead moment. Don't judge me. Jenna's already judging me enough. So just, you know, you can rest. I judged you, and then it was over,
because then you pointed out that great other fact about your outfit. Thank you very much. You earned back my respect immediately. OK, next week is basketball. Basketball, one of my favorites. When we became best friends. We became best friends.
And basketball. While shooting the basketball episode, we're gonna tell you all about it. We'll tell you all about it. All right, see ya. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created
in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.